des modest 9-noon test drive irvine ho
dyson hofer introduces the new smart
getting as much room as possible into a
small space is still the main idea
proportion is what counts he explains
that bodyspace index for cars is like
body mass index for people which tells
whether you've got a bit too much meat
on your bones a car is measured from the
accelerator to the rear hatch for the
smart it's 75% a smart benchmark now
we'll take a look at the smarts other
qualities that's Conda smart as a buzon
de school buses on snow so tall fat
Shannon sets done the design has changed
radically this car is far more boxy but
it still retains its compact car
cuteness and can travel Barcelona's
narrow streets with space to spare after
a decade on the market it's still up to
its old tricks too
like parking perpendicular rather than
parallel to the curb that's completa fox
smart smart riddle tells us the vehicle
has been given a one hundred percent
overhaul he shows us the smart shell
complete with a revamp try Dion roll
cage of super hard steel to make the new
version even safer he adds that the car
has many new safety assist systems 14
crosswinds is already standard equipment
now there's a special feature called
connectivity which will keep the car in
touch with the internet to receive
traffic data live these technologies are
all new Medina part time this is what
the new frame looks like safety for
driver and passenger are provided within
this special tri-d on single shell in
the smart edition number one it's a
high-visibility orange trademark a wired
smart logo proudly trims the front
and on the hatch the chrome tells you
the driver is clever too even if its
exterior dimensions are much smaller
than a VW polos the smart has almost as
much trunk space and when it comes to
maneuverability the smart is tough to
top Ivana in deadly cold I hope says he
wants to find out whether the new smart
will surpass its predecessors
record-breaking tight turning radius of
eight metre sixty five centimeters the
latest model is supposed to shave a
whopping 1.7 meters off of that a man in
the driver seat says just when it seems
you've hit the limit the car turns more
six metres ninety five centimeters is no
problem the smart fortwo edition one we
took for a spin as a 52 kilowatt
three-cylinder engine and germany it
starts selling at just under 14 thousand
euros with a top speed of 151 km/h it's
a little slow for the Autobahn but co2
emissions of just 93 grams per kilometer
make up for that
they're not as not as comfortable a new
smart is more comfortable than earlier
edition says line hood but it's still
not exactly a smooth ride a car with a
short a wheelbase is much more jittery
than a long sedan like an s-class
Mercedes or an Audi a8 the smart is also
10 centimetres wider meaning it's
heavier and that the two people inside
have about as much room as they would in
a VW Golf opel astra or Ford Focus the
interior isn't just cleaner its design
is also exceptional the infotainment
display seems to float just away from
the dashboard with an easy view for
drivers edition one features orange
netting which may not appeal to all
tastes slimy turmoils acting like a two
metre sixty nine centimeters long says I
note the modern smart is still a real
car it's got a hood a comfortable
passenger compartment and the latest and
safety features such as crosswind assist
the smart is small but relatively tall
so when you're speeding down the
Autobahn and the storm crosswind assist
is a big help but safety comes at a cost
not only at the dealership but in terms
of weight too with a tri-d in roll cage
the smart weighs in at eight hundred 80
kilograms so fuel consumption is as high
as in a four seater yes it's
we give this visionary concept a green
light after all art large cars carrying
just one person still the plague of
crowded city streets if more people
drove smart cars space would be a
smaller problem in urban areas it's
great for singles or childless couples
who want to move quickly through cities
or the countryside
you